[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur TVfil 78
pour un nouveau 78 société pour ce
dernier débat de la saison nous nous
demandons si le bac le baccalauréat sert
encore à quelque chose vous pouvez poser
toutes vos questions à nos invités en
passant par le Twitter de l'émission
htag 7 h sociétés comme chaque année
nous avons le droit aux mêmes scène de
lycéenes et lycéens amassés devant les
tableaux de résultats du baccalauréat
pour certains c'est la joie d'avoir
décroché le fameux sésame pour d'autres
il faudra au mieux une séance de
rattrapage au pire refaire une année
terminale dans cette émission nous
essaierons de comprendre pourquoi le
black et le diplôme qui suscite le plus
d'attente dans un parcours scolaire
général technologique professionnel
attend des lycéens ou plutôt des parents
quelle est son utilité pour accéder au
monde professionnel ne s'agit it-il que
d'une porte d'entrée vers des études
supérieurs pourquoi est-il souvent
insuffisant pour rentrer dans les
grandes écoles enfin quelle est la
valeur d'un diplôme obtenu en moyenne
par plus de 8 candidats sur 10 pour
répondre à ces questions quatre invités
autour de la table François André
d'abord bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
président de la FCPE donc la Fédération
des conseils de parents d'élèves du 78
oui Christian buisson bonsoir bonsoir
vous êtes responsable de la Cité des
Métiers de saintantiveline c'est ça les
team bonsoir bonsoir connu déjà des des
téléspectateurs de TVfil vous êtes
diplômé de Sciences Po chroniqueur sur
la radio marmite FM et fondateur
notamment du traapi blog et enfin
Mathilde Edmond bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes élèves en classe préparatoire BCPST
biologie chimie physique et sciences de
la Terre à Paris et vous avez passé
votre bac si je ne dis pas de bêtises il
y a 3 ans 2 ans 2 ans 2 ans voilà donc
vous nous direz justement si ce bac vous
a servi à quelque chose ou pas alors
pourquoi pas commencer par par cette
question
peut-être sur l'attente qui est faite
autour du bac un diplôme qui finalement
ne donne pas forcément accès à l'emploi
mais plutôt est un diplôme transitoire
pour permettre d'aller faire des études
supérieures pourquoi suscite-il tant
d'attente François André peut-être pour
commencer oui alors je suis pas d'accord
sur le fait qu'il ne soit pas un accès à
l'emploi parce que la moitié des bacs
aujourd'hui sont pas des bacs généraux
c'est les bacs technologiques et
professionnels et le Bac Pro a été créé
conçu pour permettre l'accès à l'emploi
donc les les jeunes sont sont capables
sont normalement am ils ont une
formation professionnelle qui leur
permet de trouver un emploat donc il
faut si on parle de tous les bacs à la
fois ce soir faut pas oublier qu'il y a
des bacs qui accèdent qui donne accès à
l'emploi alors maintenant notre système
français on l'a construit sur l'accès à
l'université donc il faut une étape
validante c'est une forme de validation
des acquis on peut critiquer sa forme
actuelle mais on a à chaque fois besoin
de ce genre de de d'étape ou de Pier
angulaire dans le système éducatif pour
pour passer un palier un palier
supérieur on va continuer premier tour
de table mais dtime sur la même question
en fait moi l'idée que j'ai surtout en
tête c'est que si on n pas le bac ou si
on n pas le bac professionnel et
qu'avant on n pas eu de beep ou de cap
on n'est pas condamné au chômage mais on
a de grandes chances d'être au chômage
puisque 4 ans après la sortie du système
scolaire sans aucun diplôme ouais les
jeunes sortis sans aucun diplôme sont
pour 40 % d'entre eux au chômage en
sachant que il y en a qui sont même pas
comptabilisé dans les chiffres officiels
du chômage parce qu'il se présente plus
au Pôle Emploi donc le bac en tout en
tout cas le bac qui n'est pas
professionnel permet rarement d'accéder
directement à l'emploi mais si on n pas
si on a aucun bac et en fait aucun
diplôme là on a de grandes difficultés
quand même pour s'insérir à l'emploi
donc dans cette mesure là le bac quand
même est protecteur Christian buisson
euh moi je verrai le bac un petit peu
comme cette quête du Graal des temps
modernes tout le monde vise le bac
pourquoi pourquoi faire c'est une bonne
question pourquoi pourquoi faire voilà
et donc effectivement le bac le bac
général d'une part mais aussi les bacs
enfin les filières professionnelles qui
permettent quand même surtout sur tous
les cursus suivis en CFA qui permettent
quand même d'accéder à un emploi voilà
qui permettent quand même d'accéder à un
emploi de manière assez certaine alors
mathildeedmont c'était le Graal pour
pour vous d'obtenir ce bac euh c'est sûr
que moi c'était surtout j'avais
l'impression que ça avait surtout une
valeur une valeur symbolique déjà faut
savoir que dans ma famille tout le monde
n' n'a pas le bac euh donc c'était je
pense bah pour moi et pour ma famille
déjà une une fierté puisque le bac c'est
ça a vraiment une valeur de de symbole
quoi c'est aujourd'hui il faut avoir le
bac tout le monde doit avoir le bac et
il est vrai que après dans une recherche
d'emploi c'est possible moi j'ai des
amis qui l'ont fait des des parents de
trouver un emploi sans avoir son bac
mais il est vrai que entre un un
candidat même pour un emploi qui ne
requierre pas le bac comme ça qui a son
bac et un qui ne l'a pas bah on va va
privilégier celui qui a le bac ne
serait-ce que parce que ça a une valeur
symbolique just une petite différence
quand même même si ça va pas être
peut-être la chose la plus importante
mais ça peut faire une petite différence
sur le CV à la fin et et cette valeur
symbolique que vous portiez vous sur le
bac avant de le passer l'image que vous
vous en faisiez peut-être ensuite c'est
ce qui s'est avéré être ou bien vous
vous êtes dit que finalement bah c'était
juste une période transitoire pour
rentrer en classe pr préparatoire
ensuite c'est sûr que moi j'avais depuis
longtemps l'idée d'entrer en classe
préparatoire et de toute manière les
classes préparatoires comme beaucoup
d'écoles dans les études
supérieures sont obtenu donc on est
admis sous réserve d'obtention du
baccalauréat donc les admissions se font
avant l'obtention du bac mais si on l'a
pas ça n'a l'admission n'est pas validée
donc pour moi c'était c'était quelque
chose d'obligatoire puisque c'était ce
que je voulais faire dans mon parcours
professionnel maintenant je pense pas
forcément que le bac ou le bac général
plus particulièrement soit une
obligation pour des gens qui voudraient
suivre un cursus qui pour lequel ce
n'est pas nécessaire finalement alors
Mathilde nous parler à l'instant de de
valeur symbolique est-ce que my c'est
une valeur symbolique pour tous les
bacheliers ou est-ce que c'est plus une
valeur symbolique pour je sais pas les
classes populaires qui pourrai y voir
une sorte je sais pas d'ascension social
en obtenant le bac comme disait
mathildem à l'instant toute sa
famille n'a pas le bac alors déjà je
pense qu'il faut distinguer le type de
bac parce que le bac le le symbole
associé au bac professionnel ou au bac
technique n'est pas le même que le
symbole associé au bac général voire au
bac S au sein de ces bacs
généraux il est évident que en France en
tout cas le type de bac est corrélé en
fait à la à la à l'origine sociale des
élèves c'està-dire que chez les cadres
supérieurs ou les professions
intellectuelles le les les enfants qui
ont un bac professionnel sont vraiment
très très minoritaires et ceux qui ont
un bac général sont ultra majoritaires
donc du coup c'est le genre de de de de
milieux sociau professionnels dans
lequel c'est pas tout c'est pas vraiment
envisageable en fait statistiquement de
ne pas avoir un bac général donc le le
rôle symbolique du bac il est beaucoup
plus fort en fait dans les dans les
classes populaires c'estd que les
enfants qui sont vraiment issus de
parents qui sont inactifs par parce que
peut-être très très loin du marché de
l'emploi ont de grandes chances en fait
d'avoir un un bac pro en fait quand ils
ont le bac donc si ces enfantsl ces
enfants-là ont un bac général alors là
le le le bac a une valeur très une
valeur symbolique très très forte h
François André B il a pas qu'une valeur
symbolique quand même il a une valeur
pratique c'est c'est la porte ça ouvre
la porte d'accès à un grand nombre de
formations donc encore une fois on a
bâti notre système éducatif sur cette
pierre angulaire donc son intérêt
premier c'est d'ouvrir les portes de
l'enseignement supérieur et et puis pour
les bac pro de de former avant ce ce
niveau c'est à un métier donc pour le
moment je vois pas ce qu'on peut lui
reprocher sauf peut-être tout ce qui est
décrié dans la presse son prix son coût
sa lourdeur de
d'organisation et si on veut changer de
système ça veut dire qu'on change
aussi notre échelle de valeur sur les
sur les filières et qu'on change aussi
l'organisation des filières en
particulier l'université les grandes
écoles et les prépas réaction rapide de
de medilam parce que vous avez utiliser
un mot intéressant qui est métier puis
je donne la parole à chrand qu'en fait
le le le bac per permet d'accéder aux
études supérieures et notamment à
l'université mais simplement le taux
d'échec des des bacheliers qui sont issu
du du baccalauréat professionnel voire
technique dans des filières comme la
médecine ou le droit qui sont très
sélectives est beaucoup plus important
voilà c'est ça et donc du coup le taux
d'échec est corrélé en fait au type de
bac qui a été qui a été obtenu quand on
accède en fait à aux formations
universitaires alors est-ce que le but
de l'école c'est c'est avoir un métier
alors justement à quoi ça sert d'aller à
l'école alors peut-être quand on
s'engage dans une filière générale pour
obtenir un bac général l'objectif c'est
peut-être d'acquérir une un certain
niveau de de culture générale et d'aller
plus loin et d'aller voilà il y a voilà
enfin on peut voir le bac comme un
passeport pour après accéder à d'autres
d'autres cursus sans compter le fait que
même dans le dans les cursus lié à la
formation professionnelle pour adulte
parfois il faut quand même avoir validé
un bac général même un bac un bac même
siil a 20 ans pour pouvoir intégrer
d'autres cursus dans le cadre de la
formation professionnelle pour adultes
après l'école ça sert à apprendre le bac
le bac général pour moi il apprend à
apprendre et et ensuite les filières
professionnelles elles permettent de se
rapprocher le plus possible du
monde du du du monde du travail parce
qu'on peut on se rend compre quas absent
du du du collège ou du lycée on
demandera touthe question quand même
dans enfin autour de la question de
l'orientation il il y a cette question
là il y a comment on apprend à connaître
un métier comment on apprend à connaître
qu'est-ce que c'est que l'économie au
sens large qu'est-ce que c'est qu'une
entreprise comment elle évol enfin oui
comment elle vit dans quel environnement
elle vit et cetera c'est un peu ce que
vous faites à la Cité des Métiers vous
essay de proposer des voà je peux
expliquer un petit peu à la Cité des
Métiers on essaie de mettre en relation
ben le monde entre autres en direction
des jeunes le monde éducatif et le monde
du travail élaborer son projet
professionnel c'est complexe ça se fait
pas enfin comme tu disais tout à l'heure
ça se fait pas ça prend du temps
d'élaborer son projet professionnel
alors peut-être que c certains jeunes à
16 ou 17 ans ils n'en sont pas encore à
élaborer un projet professionnel mais
peut-être que certains sont déjà à ce à
ce stade
là générale par contre mais par contre
où est l'accompagnement à l'élaboration
du projet
professionnel voilà demandé à une
ancienne lycéenne alors est-ce que vous
aviez en tout cas dans votre parcours
scolaire est-ce que vous avez
suffisamment eu d'informations sur les
métiers possibles que vous pouvez vous
vous avez de la chance vous allez vous
voulez être vétérinaire donc vous avez
une idée claire depuis depuis assez
longtemps qu'estce quel est le le cas
pour les autres camarades que vous aviez
au lycée ou peut-être au collège alors
pour les pour les camarades pour les
camarades que j'avais effectivement j'ai
trouvé queil y avait un manque
d'accompagnement et d'information ouis
c'est-à-dire que j'ai des camarades qui
ont découvert des écoles euh une semaine
avant de passer le bas quand c'était
déjà trop tard pour APB pour les
demandes voir qui font une année d'étude
et puis qui au final vont se dire au
bout d'un an mais c'est pas du tout ce
que je veux faire en fait il y avait
aussi telle chose dont j'ai jamais
entendu parler dont j'avais aucune idée
et et personne ne m'en a jamais parlé
et déjà c'est j'ai trouvé quand j'étais
au collège que c'était extrêmement
difficile d'avoir un rendez-vous avec un
conseiller d'orientation et même avec ça
c'est difficile de finalement pour
quelqu'un qui ne sait pas du tout ce qui
lui plaît et où il veut aller de trouver
des idées des possibilités des écoles
voir des formations professionnel
directement qui lui permettrait
d'atteindre son but alors c'est très
intéressant parce que là on rentre dans
un débat très français sur bah le lien
sur l'orientation et puis est-ce que on
forme à
l'école des futurs employés de marque
qu' tiera pas de des fut de grandes
entreprises ou autres oou est-ce qu'on
forme d'abord des esprits ou les deux
déjà je pense que l'un n'empêche pas
l'autre et puis l'idée que ce soit une
grande entreprise ou une petite
entreprise change pas grand-chose ce qui
est important pour qu'un jeune soit
intégré au modèle social français c'est
que déjà ils puissent travailler et
c'est une problématique qui est très
sensible au niveau des bacs
professionnel puisque une partie des
élèves qui sont diplômés en fait du bac
pro peuvent envisager de rentrer sur le
marché du travail en étant un minimum
compétent le problème de l'orientation
notamment en bac pro elle est décisive
parce qu'on se rend compte en fait que
une grande partie des décrocheurs
scolaires qui décrochent euh assez
massivement quand même au niveau de la
formation du bac pro décroche en raison
dis-il d'une mauvaise orientation d'une
orientation qui correspond pas du tout à
leurs besoinsou donc au niveau du bac
pro il y a un gros gros travail me
semble-t-il à faire euh d'information en
fait des élèves voire de réflexion sur
les métiers du futur euh qu'il faut
qu'il faut commencer à appréhender au
sein de l'éducation nationale et à posé
au au niveau des jeunes parce que quand
une orientation ce qui a été mon cas
n'est pas tout à fait choisie après un
bac général il y a des systèmes qui
permettent après un semestre de
d'université de d'accéder à d'autres
types de formation au niveau des bacs
professionnels c'est beaucoup plus
problématique parce que vous étiez passé
d'abord par l'université avant de de
faire science pour François André ben
c'est ce qu'on demande à la FCPE depuis
un moment c'est que à force de parler
des filières pro moi depuis que j'ai des
responsabilités dans C cette fédération
je ne vois que se fermer des formations
professionnelles parce que l'État se
désengage et l'État veut envoyer plus de
gens parce que ça lui coûte moins cher
c'est vraiment une grossière question
d'argent hein ça lui coûte moins cher
d'avoir un élève en seconde générale ou
première générale que de l'avoir dans
une seconde pro où ce sont des sections
de 12 ou 24 et où il faut en plus des
ateliers donc on a fait un choix qui est
un choix de société les Français s'en
rendent peut-être pas compte mais à
force de de comprimer les budgets ce
qu'on fait c'est c'est que on ferme les
voies professionnelles euh et et en
particulier le libre choix c'est-à-dire
que il faut remplir les
trous l'obsession d'un rectorat c'est de
remplir toutes ces formations
professionnelles et donc s'il y a de la
place à tel endroit et que tel autre est
trop demandé il poussera des élèves vers
l'endroit où il reste quelques places
mais on optimise ce qu'on a et on a
fermé on a fermé sur le rectorat de
Versailles en 10ant on a fermé une
dizaine de BTS et c'était une des
formation postback un peu rapide et
accessible à beaucoup d'élèves gratuite
euh qui permettait l'ascenseur sociale
pour beaucoup d'élèves on a fermé des
BTS et et ça personne n'a rien pu faire
contre ça c'est la raison d'État c'est
la raison de budget et ça faut faire
très attention parce qu'on est en train
de pousser beaucoup de gens vers le
général al soyons clair aussi François
André la plupart des parents je suis sûr
que si on faisait un sondage dirait
qu'il préfèrent voir leurs enfants en
filière générale on a tous le souvenir
hein de discussion avec un copain
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire la l'année
prochaine ben je vais faire un CAP un
beep ah d'c
quand il va en seconde générale ah ouais
donc du cé par pas et puis c'est lieu
aussi à la à une dévalorisation très
française des filières professionnelles
parce que nous notre modèle de réussite
c'est le monde académique c'est les
grandes écoles et c'est ce qui c'est ça
a pour conséquence que notamment
vis-à-vis de d'économie comme
l'Allemagne nous avons des entreprises
notamment industrielles qui sont
beaucoup moins performante que ce qu'il
y a en Allemagne parce qu'en Allemagne
en fait la la voie professionnelle est
bien bien mieux et bien bien plus
valorisé que qu'elle l'est en qu'elle
l'est en France et c'est ce qui explique
en partie le manque de compétitivité de
l'économie française et de l'industrie
française par rapport à l'industrie
allemande et à l'économie allemande
Christian buisson d'abord ensuite
Mathilde euh oui alors sur la
connaissance des métiers peut-être à
l'école bon l'école n'est pas faite pour
pour formmer au métier mais en tout cas
il y a il y a des dispositifs qui
existent et à la citté des métiers on
met en place plusieurs types de de enfin
il y a plusieurs types de propositions
qui peuvent permettre aux jeunes de de
de découvrir des métiers euh par
exemple des enfin des des événements des
informations collectives sur quand on
enfin on cible parfois un secteur
d'activité un métier en particulier donc
les jeunes peuvent venir s'informer des
visites d'entreprisees et cetera quand
on quand on réfléchit quand on essaie de
mettre en place son projet professionnel
il y a différentes étapes et quand on
fait un choix c'est compliqué de faire
un choix et parfois c'est un choix ou un
non choix parce que dans quel désir on
se cale dans son propre désir à soi dans
le désir des parents dans le désir de je
sais pas qui l'importance des parents et
pu est-ce qu'on est capable de faire un
choix pour demander on a 15 ans 16 ans
sur un métier un futur métier qui va
peut-être voilà guider notre parcours
professionnel moi je pense que ça dépend
des gens il y a des gens qui ont
peut-être la maturité je sais pas si
c'est vraiment une question de maturité
mais nécessaire à 15 ans pour savoir moi
plus tard je vais faire ça et il y en a
d'autres qui arrivaient même en fin de
seconde on leur dit alors elle s es et
qui sont ben je sais pas alors si j'ai
les
moyens ni un bon bagage scientifique je
vais aller en S mais malheureusement
c'est c'est des choix par défaut et mais
encore une fois parce que on n pas enfin
on n pas de réelle idée je pense à 15 16
ans de à quoi ça va m'amener si je fais
lelle à quoi ça va m'amener si je fais s
alors le discours qu'on entend c'est bah
si tu fais s tu pourras tout
faire on l'entend souvent alors c'est
pas forcément vrai et pour avoir
accompagné quand même pardon pour avoir
accompagné quand même pas mal d'adultes
dans un projet de reconversion ou
d'évolution professionnelle le nombre
d'adultes qui après 15 ans d'expérience
professionnelle un parcours déjà
construit se disent non mais moi je vais
passer un cap de donc ça existe alors
vous parlez tout à l'heure François and
tout ce qu'on entend dans la presse euh
alors quel est le VUR ben justement il
chaque année c'est un maronier comme on
ditjour alors quelle est la valeur
justement c'est ce qui a été posé d'un
diplôme qui est obtenu parfois par 90 %
des candidats euh alors j'ai les
chiffres pour les Yvelines par exemple
pour les filières générales je l'ai sous
les yeux les candidats évelinois donc
c'est 93,6 % de réusscite un taux en
baisse en plus he par rapport à 2015 0,5
pour une moyenne académique d'à peu près
91 11 % en filière technologique 91 % de
réussite en filière professionnelle 80,8
% de réussite ça rejoint un peu ce que
disait MAM tout à l'heure ça augmenté
oui oui ça ça a augmenté euh mais voilà
quelle est la valeur qu'on peut donner à
vous vous vous réfléchissez attention
aux chiffres he ça cache des choses vous
réfléchissez en terme de pourcentage de
ceux qui se sont présentés au
baccalauréat c'est pas le pourcentage
d'une génération c'est pas le reflet euh
vous me facilitez la transition va voir
apparître justement graphique avec la
proportion des bacheliers dans les
générations de 80 à à 2014 et vous voyez
la courbe qui est exponentielle donc les
bacs professionnels qui n'existaient qui
n'existaient pas évidemment avant avant
88 donc les bacs technologiques
également mais qui perdent un petit peu
du terrain et puis le B général qui est
toujours au-dessus alors par exemple
pour on a que 20 % d'une tranche d'âge
c'est ça exactement 20 % d'une tranche
d'âge en 4 en 1980 contre maintenant
78,3 % donc 70 18,3 % des personnes en
nâ de passer de passer le bac on le bac
en France alors qu'est-ce que vous
voulez euh dire par là ah bah justement
c'est c'est ce que vous vouliez me dire
tout à l'heure Rapp c'est si c'est pour
nous entraîner dans l'éternel débat sur
le niveau du bac euh le bac qu'on a
passé n'a rien à voir avec celui
d'aujourd'hui donc les défis qu'ont les
jeunes maintenant euh c'est de
comprendre le monde qui les entour c'est
de parler des langues euh nous étions
certainement beaucoup plus mauvais en
anglais qu'eux euh donc c'est on n pas
on n pas à chaque époque des disciplines
sont en pointe et des niveaux d'exigence
sont plus les mêmes et puis aussi
c'était probablement le reflet de
l'ascension sociale à cette époque-là je
trouve que ça devrait être une fierté
pour un pays de dire qu'au contraire il
a 77 % d'une classe d'âge qui est amené
au niveau baccalauréat c'est un vrai
défi et c'est un défi de massification
de l'éducation qu'on a réussi malgré ce
que disent les mauvaises langues et en
parti en souvent les mauvaises langues
politiqu donc je trouve et on a aussi
des objectifs qui ont été qui sont ceux
de l'Europe d'augmenter le niveau des
populations et le niveau de formation
des populations pour les préparer au
métiers d'avenir et à à résoudre un
certain nombre de défis qui vont se
poser dans les années qui viennent donc
il faut C ce chiffre là ben demandons au
de aux deux personnes ici mediltim qui
lui a a réussi à passer à avoir un
diplôme d'une grande école donc de
sciences pour Paris et puis Mathilde
également qui s'est inscrit en classe
préparatoire est-ce que ça sous-entend
que le bac n'était pas suffisamment armé
pour que vous puissiez directement
passer peut-être pour Mathilde en tout
cas en classe préparatoire ou pour MDI
par d'autres par d'aut d'autres chemins
moi je pense que le système scolaire et
ça c'est aussi un problème français il
doit la norme du système scolaire
français doit pas être les classes
préparatoires à les grandes écoles
combien il y a d'enfants qui vont en
classe préparatoire et dans les grandes
écoles je veux dire et c'est on sait
toujours quoi statistiquement on sait
que c'est des enfants qui sont plutôt
privilé ég qui viennent de de de FAM
n'est pas le cas de mathlddemont par
exemple qui est oui ni mon cas mais ce
qu'il y a c'est que quand en tout cas
statistiquement il y a une reproduction
sociale au niveau des des grandes écoles
qui est qui est qui qui est qui est
horrible quoi socialement parlant donc
ça doit vraiment ça doit pas être ça la
norme la norme me semble-t-il ça devrait
être dans un monde dans lequel on a
besoin aujourd'hui d'une formation ce
qui était pas le cas il y a 40 ans on
pouvait très bien
travailler avoir un un emploi sans avoir
de diplôme il y a 40 ans beaucoup plus
facilement qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui on
a 17 entre 16 et 17 % d'une classe d'âge
en moyenne 140000 jeunes chaque année
qui sortent du système scolaire sans
diplôme et ces jeunes-là en fait ont
vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de mal
contrairement à ce qui se passa il y a
40 ans à avoir un emploi donc ce qui est
important pour nous c'est pas de savoir
si le bac S permet d'accéder aux grandes
écoles ça on s'en fiche je veux dire ce
qui pourrait être intéressant oui mais
pour une minorité d'élèves être une
formation générale qui permett à tout le
monde d'être sur un P d'égalité sauf si
c'est évidemment c'est c'est de la
publicité alors oui mais c'est c'est
quoi ça correspond à quoi 2 3 % maximum
des des des élèves qui qui font des
classes prépa ou des grandes écoles moi
ce qui m'intéresse plus pour l'égalité
en France c'est que fait-on de ces 17 %
de jeunes chaque année qui n'ont pas qui
sortent du système scolaire sansun
diplôme sans diplôme Mathilde alors moi
ce que ce que j' dire déjà c'est
qu'effectivement une société c'est pas
uniquement des ingénieurs c'est pas
uniquement des gens qui sortent de
classe prépa c'est tout un ensemble de
catégorie de métier qui vont on peut
être ouvrier on peut être ingénieur on
peut faire plein de choses dans une
société et alors chercher
l'hyperspécialisation les plus longues
études possibles c'est pas toujours un
but à viser il faut aussi effectivement
se concentrer sur toute une partie de la
population qui va faire des des métiers
qui sont tout aussi utiles à la société
tout aussi importants et que eux auront
peut-être plus envie de faire tout le
monde n'a pas envie d'être président
d'une grande entreprise et ça c'est très
important et aujourd'hui en France je
trouve qu'on tend un peu trop à pousser
les gens à faire le plus d'études poss
possiblebles euh alors qu'au final déjà
c'est pas forcément ce qu'ils ont envie
de faire et c'est pas non plus ce qui va
être forcément le plus utile à la
société deuxièmement j'aimerais bien
qu'on arrête de dire tous les ans au aux
lycéens que le bac c'est facile oui
parce que le bac euh c'est pas facile
peut-être que le niveau qui est requis
ce qui n'a pas été dit ici hein non non
bien sûr et peut-être que le niveau qui
est requis est facilement euh
atteignable en en travaillant et déjà
c'est pas forcément sûr c'est pas pour
tout le monde tout le monde n'a pas les
mêmes capacités de travail et
d'apprentissage mais en plus c'est un
examen qui est stressant c'est en
quelque sorte un premier examen avec le
brevet des collèges et on peut être très
bon dans ces études et rater son bac à
cause du stress à cause de la pression
et le fait que certains veulent le
passer en en contô le continu et c'est
une pression supplémentaire qui est sur
qui est mis sur les élèves tous les ans
en leur disant mais c'est bon le bac
c'est facile de toute façon tout le
monde donc déjà c'est très dévalorisant
pour les gens qui n'ont pas leur bac et
ça peut être un accident comme ça peut
être des difficultés scolaires donc déjà
c'est très dévalorisant c'est des gens
qui ont du mal après même à s'insérer
dans la vie professionnelle parce qu'ils
se disent de toute façon je ne veux rien
j'ai j'ai raté mon bac alors que c'est
pas du tout vrai c'est pas parce qu'on a
raté son bac qu' qu'on ne veut rien
derrière et puis et puis c'est stressant
aussi de dire c'est facile c'est facile
à tout le monde alors que ça ça n pas
effectivement surtout quand surtout
quand on l'a pas Christian buisson ce
sera votre conclusion euh oui bah du
coup je je reviendrai peut-être sur sur
comment on fait son choix et pour faire
descendre un petit peu aussi la pression
de de ce fameux choix à l'âge de 17 ans
on va dire ou plus tard mais bon
aujourd'hui c'est fini c'est fini les
parcours linéaire c'est fini une
carrière entière dans la même entreprise
dans le même métier on va être amené à
sûrement exercer plusieurs métiers et ça
va tellement vite que c'est difficile
aussi de se projeter sur quel métiers
vont être porteurs dans je sais pas
voilà c'est difficile donc pour juste
faire descendre un peu cette pression il
faut se dire que je fais un choix
aujourd'hui mais ce choix je vais
peut-être le remettre en question dans
je sais pas 10 ans émission est terminée
vous avez 10 secondes Françis Andr alors
est-ce qu'on peut inviter les auditeurs
à lire un texte passionnant qui est
sorti il y a une quinzaine de jours qui
fait une trentaine de pages qui
s'appelle comment réformer le bac et qui
est sorti de Terranova qui est un S tank
assez connu
et qui propose des pistes
extraordinaires on sait pas pourquoi
aujourd'hui la ministre tout à l'heure a
annoncé qu' qu'elle allait toiletter le
bac voil donc en attendant le toilettage
du bac par par la ministre
actuation la information franç merci à
tous les quatre merci d'avoir euh
participé à ce débat qui était très
intéressant on aurait pu encore parler
he des heures et des heures émission
vous pouvez retrouver sur le Podcast de
la radio TVfil 78.com c'était le dernier
débat de la saison j'en profite donc
pour remarquer pour remercier pardon
toutes les équipes de TVfil 78 il fait
très chaud sur le plateau euh qui
travaillent donc ces équipes aussi bien
à la rédaction qu'à la technique toute
l'année pour essayer de vous donner le
meilleur de l'actualité locale donc
merci à eux bonne suite de programme
bonne soirée bonne été vous avez si vous
avez de la chance d'être en vacances et
puis on se retrouve à la rentrée pour de
nouveaux débats
[Musique]
merci